with the stroke of a pen president Trump
vetoed the bipartisan legislation that
rejected his declaration to get funding
for a border wall but the unpopular
measure is still facing resistance from
lawmakers who say they will fight it
Nikole Killion has more from the White
House Nicole good morning good morning
to you Dana and for the first time in
his presidency President Trump used his
veto power to reject what he called a
reckless resolution Congress has the
freedom to pass this resolution and I
have the duty to veto it
surrounded by cabinet members sheriffs
and relatives of those killed by
undocumented immigrants president Trump
rebuked lawmakers who overrode his
emergency declaration Congress vote to
deny the crisis on the southern border
is a vote against reality
it's against reality it is a tremendous
national emergency it is a tremendous
crisis the yeas are 59 the nays are 41 a
dozen Republican senators joined their
Democratic colleagues to reverse the
president's declaration out of concern
that he was exceeding his authority the
president can't overrule the decision of
Congress without becoming the ultimate
power as opposed to a balancing power
this check on the executive is a source
of our freedom in addition this
precedent or this declaration is a
dangerous precedent who is going to pay
for the wall it was an embarrassing blow
to the president from his own party on
an issue that was a key promise of his
presidential campaign
yesterday he minimized their actions I
could have gotten some of them to come
along I said I want you to vote your
heart do what you want to do I'm not
putting any pressure mr. Trump declared
the emergency last month after Congress
authorized less than a quarter of the
5.7 billion dollars he was seeking to
build a wall along the southern border
the move would allow the president to
divert funds from the military to make
up the difference House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi says heard
will vote to override the President's
veto later this month that would require
a two-thirds majority in both the House
and Senate which for now Anthony seems
unlikely Nicole thank you very much